[inaudible] on Youtube.
Everybody would like hundreds of people go.
Like I just started watching that youtube recommended that to me.
Like how did that happen?
You know,
this little guy with a tow truck company does now pushed on everybody's laps and
now he just went over 100,000 subscribers the other day and it was like months
ago that he was just had like 10 that that,
that's the argument.
Some people have made that that's how fast the Paul brothers,
they grew and they grew so fast on youtube that some people thought there was
something up that game,
like millions of followers within a week or two of being on there and they were
coming from another platform.
Well it's also coming from another platform is giant,
but it's also all it really takes is one person deciding that whatever the fuck
you did was funny or weird or crazy like that cashew outside girl.
Oh yeah.
Well there's that grows,
you know,
managed by the same people that own TMZ and that's why you see it on Tmz.
Every guy was going to bring up,
if you want the fire,
the fire festival documentary,
there's a,
an explanation of this show,
how this,
uh,
they spread the,
the fuck Jerry guys,
the marketing teams spread that with the orange picture and it was a coordinated
event over hundreds of different social media accounts for her,
for the cash me outside girl for the fire festival.
Yeah.
Firefox to,
to catch everybody's,
because there are a team of people,
there are agencies that have all this influence your accounts.
They pay them.
They don't have to accept the money or accept the offer except the campaign.
But oftentimes they do.
So it's like a talent agency.
100%.
Yeah.
They don't need to share a new person,
your launch,
the next thing,
the next voice,
and it's like,
oh,
here's a new song.
There's a new movie.
It's just a new way to suppress stuff,
bro.
It's pretty cool watching how many people are unsubscribing?
Fuck Jerry and the fat Jew though.
That's it.
But are they,
I looked at it the other day.
It was day of like 14 million.
It was 500,000 in like a weekend really is a significant amount of I,
it really was 14.7 then it was 14.1 haven't looked whoa.
That's coming in from,
I think of video.
Someone shared this week.
I think Vic Berger made a video that got spread around and they took his video,
right?
Maybe.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
I think I saw it on Vicksburg burgers page.
Here's a few comics.
I have posted videos like,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
fat Jews stole this.
I tried to reach out and they never got back to me.
He got 10 million w w what do you think about this idea though?
Like that's kind of piracy,
you know,
like,
and so Instagram is allowing and Twitter's allowing piracy.
Well,
I think they're allowing these people to post videos because you don't really
know where it came from.
There's no proof.
Right?
Like if you find a meme,
like how many times he posted a meme,
I repost whoever sent it to me.
If someone sends it to me,
but sometimes I'll just find it in a Google search and you've got to figure out
who made that meme.
And if I find their Instagram account then I'll try to find it and repost it.
But some people don't.
And I have it in the past like a,
I did that one with a baked Alaska got mad at me cause there was one with Alex
Jones sitting in a hot tub and it's a,
it's like when your friends are trying to chill and,
but you have to keep dropping truth bombs.
It was,
I didn't know it was his right.
I just posted it because someone sent to me,
someone sent it to me in a text message.
I think.
Um,
but those things have a creator.
Right.
And uh,
I know Pete,
like Eddie Bravo makes his own.
He makes them sometimes,
but he'll send some to me or post some online that he finds that are funny too.
And everybody tries to credit the person who did it right.
But now what they do is they,
they take it and they credit the person,
but they didn't for so long.
They're not attempt.
They're crediting fake accounts.
So they'll make a,
so they're not getting busted in the way you were just explaining.
I've seen that too.
Well what is that about though?
Cause that seems like deception the way around the back door and that
qualification of it needs to be on an account.
We need to point to somebody,
okay,
well we'll point to this account,
but it's not even a real account.
Right.
And if they find like they,
they'll post stuff and then later add the person because the person contacts
them and said,
they're almost like that's admitting to piracy.
Like we did hire though.
I mean,
because if they just repost it,
a lot of folks including me do that.
Yeah.
But they're making the person making money or not.
Um,
that's important.
I don't make any money off my Instagram.
Right.
They're making millions.
Yeah.
I just,
uh,
I've been offered to post stuff up and I'm not saying that I wouldn't,
if something was fucking killer and they wanted to give me money,
I'm greedy.
I'll take some money.
But I wouldn't lie about it.
An A and a I haven't yet.
I've never accepted any money yet.
Yeah.
Because it's also,
I think in Instagram's,
uh,
you know,
law that you have to put that it's an ad if you're making money off of it.
And so that's nother thing that both fuck Jerry and fat you are not doing,
they're not putting in cad is it?
I just wanted like to devil's advocate this though is is there a place for them
for those accounts?
Like is there a place to have to be the re tweeter of the memes to be that guy
to be that account,
you know,
like Oh,
isn't that valuable?
So yes,
it is a curator position.
Yeah.
It's kind of valuable.
But the question is like if it,
if it is valuable and it becomes something low,
almost like redistributing your standup.
If you're doing a set,
like if up sets where you know something that you just,
you could get everywhere and you could just repost it on your page,
but then your page became super popular because there are all these people stand
up sets,
you know,
like a Spotify.
Spotify gets ads,
right,
but they don't really,
they pay the artists a little bit,
but mostly they're making all the money.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's like say sorry later you just do it and say,
I'm sorry,
I'm gonna figure it out after the fact.
Or you figure it out.
Business oriented things that have art in them as opposed to art oriented,
things that start making money.
There are two very different things.
So this is not an art thing.
This is a,
they find other people's art and they sell it.
They're pushing it,
they create these accounts.
The accounts get giant.
People pass it around because they're just finding funny things and then they
start profiting.
But all the people that created all the intellectual property get zero money,
which is weird.
I don't remember.
But I only learned more about this when exit through the gift shop came out.
Isn't that what Andy Warhol sort of did?
I don't know and I don't care.
I mean maybe he did.
Maybe he did,
but the PR,
the thing about it is that this is happening right now on the Internet.
It's a totally different animal.
I mean,
Andy Warhol wasn't running around taking exact photo duplicates and putting them
on his website for sale.
Like these are,
this is when someone's doing on an Instagram page is like you could within
seconds take a piece and put it somewhere else.
It's seconds.
Brian posts something.
I think it's funny.
Ha.
I go to copy,
I go to the fucking repost at a APP.
I put it in there and repost it.
It's seconds later.
You could do that all day and if you hire kids,
I don't know,
he has people working for them,
but if these guys do,
they hire people for fucking 20 bucks an hour or whatever and these people just
do it all day long.
They just find funny shit all day long.
They look for certain hashtags,
meme factories or what they're calling.
Yeah.
And there's some people like,
you know that I've made some funny ones all their own.
You know a lot of people that are just doing that all I know delete has done a
bunch of them.
And then there's also one that they do where they steal people's act and make a
meme out of it and then posted on their page.
That's where it gets even more slippery because you'd talking about like
standups,
acts the you,
you're,
you're making money off it.
How much are they making off each post?
I mean,
I don't know,
but these are multimillion dollar business and the punchline.
So now you have this 10 minute joke that everyone has the punchline because they
saw it on Facebook.
That's like,
spoiler alert Klein for sure.
If you're still doing that material.
It wasn't on Netflix or a comedy central special or something for sure.
That sucks.
I guess it's just,
it's always happened though,
hasn't it?
TV shows.
I've been accused of stealing a,
oh,
they have stolen.
It's happened on dude.
They did it to Kevin.
James,
I saw it happen.
Kevin James was at the,
uh,
he had a development deal for NBC back in the [inaudible] back when we were
young pups.
Both of us are like 27 or some shit.
Maybe he's a little older than that.
Maybe.
It's actually,
that was like during the news radio days.
So we're probably like in our thirties.
Um,
and he had this development deal,
nice development deal.
They're paying them on a lot of,
a lot of cash,
a lot of paper and a,
they were setting up a sitcom around him.
So they had him do a set at a theater in Hollywood.
And uh,
I was there and he does this set and has all these writers from various sitcoms
and the very next season,
one of his best jokes is on an episode of a television show that's very popular.
Very popular.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
they fucking stole his bit,
man.
I guess that's where I was going to,
cause that was in the 90s.
So like we're now 25,
20,
25 years later,
the new popular medium is Instagram and social media.
Yeah.
But different is that,
well it's different because there's accountability now.
Cause people know that if you wrote a meme and you put it up on your site and
then a fuck Jerry comes along and steals your shit and doesn't credit you for it
and just puts it up there,
you know what they did unless someone sent it to them and didn't attribute it to
you,
which is possible.
But it seems much more likely that what they're doing,
they were doing on purpose for the longest time and they just,
they thought that's what you could do on the Internet.
It's a wild west.
You could just take memes and you can become famous and looked at fat Jewish
guy,
did it.
I mean that guy became famous with whether you,
uh,
agree with his methods or not.
It worked.
He,
he's got his crazy hair.
You shows you,
you know,
like he's just crazy looking guy and he has all these funny memes that somebody
else wrote and they're all up on his Instagram page and it worked and people
don't like him.
Now there's a lot of people that don't like him.
People get real shitty with them in person.
They don't want him to do an appearance as they know what he did.
So there's a certain number of people that go,
hey man,
you're a thief.
Like this is not cool.
Like what you did is not cool.
But then there's certain people that don't care and then there's certain people
that think,
well,
what he did was just what anybody did back then.
It was the wild west.
No one thought about it.
And once he established that business model and it was effective,
it was probably very hard for him to slow it down or to attribute things to
people or to admit that he didn't do it for all that amount of time.
It just bugs me that companies pay these guys knowing that they do this or like
as a fat Jew,
he's like,
see,
he's like sign with ca who's signed with a bunch of comedians they probably
took,
it's taken from the same basket.
So it's like it is weird,
right?
Yeah.
Now if he was going on stage and doing their acts,
he's been doing appearances.
Right.
He's got a book.
He's been on TV shows.
Well,
I don't know what's in,
I don't know what he's doing,
what he's doing,
but maybe showing him,
but he's,
look,
he's obviously used it for profit.
He's figured out a way to profit.
It's weird.
He must be weirded out by this fuck Jerry thing too because you might be
sitting,
must be sitting there going,
okay,
all right.
Here.
I was going to leave me alone.
It's um,
you know,
comedy central was advertising on the fuck Jerry Page,
which is like Jesus folks.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
It was like Jesus folks,
can I just say you guys down,
go over a little history of comedy.
Well,
I mean mind him and see I,
they didn't learn then either,
you know.
Well that was while it was happening,
you know?
Yeah,
they did learn.
Eventually they let it go eventually.
But that was also because the ratings have dropped through the floor floor.
You know,
comedy's not fucking easy to make up,
you know,
especially like meme kind of comedy that's done by folks that are working in
offices,
meme kind of comedy.
Some of the funniest fucking comedy on earth and it's done by regular people.
It's not like a,
it's not like most memes are written by high level satirists that worked for the
New Yorker?
No,
they're regular folks who think something's funny.
You know,
I think what's going to happen is as technology improves the like being able to
scan a photo and go where are we could tell the first time this has ever been on
the Internet was from this little girl.
She took a photo of it has all the data in the picture and it's now used on this
meme that's making this much money and this.
Then it's going to be kind of broken down like you know like any kind of
artists.
Yes.
I mean that's the idea for the buyer and the argument for the blockchain getting
involved in here because I could tie that you can,
I guess it can be in the data like no.
Let me ask you this.
What if someone uses a picture of a your band,
so you have a band,
they use a picture of your band and then they have a funny meme under the
picture of your band.
Who owns that then?
That's what I have.
Like I think Beyonce tried to get that picture taken off the Internet from her
from the super bowl a couple of years ago because it was like a bad picture.
It she didn't like how she looked in it.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
but how the fuck is that lady take a bad picture?
I just,
she does some of these talk to her.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's not your best,
but you look fucking great.
Like if that shit was on Tinder,
you know you wouldn't be on,
it's like shit did it.
Who if someone was paying for that meme,
it should be on say get some of the money or that's the question that you would
have would be like a corporation,
right?
Which should someone be able to grab photos that are out in the public domain,
make something with it and then profit.
That's the way this is it.
A lot of bands.
I'm sure that's why I said banks cause they were like really good at protecting
copyright and their logo and shit.
If you had like the kiss band logo,
you don't think gene Simmons had come at you.
He's coming at you with some lawyers 100% right.
That's just what he's going to do.
But it's who owns those photos?
If it's like gene Simmons like spitting fire out and I think if you took the
photo and cameras were allowed inside the event,
you took it.
It's not what the case is though.
Most of the photographs or people that are putting up there,
just putting them up online and someone takes it like say if you gene Simmons
spitting fire and then it has a joke about eating the hookers posted or
something like whatever it is,
fill it.
Make something funny there.
But like if that's online and that becomes this giant meme that gets all these
likes and that somehow or another someone pro,
how the fuck do you profit from you from Instagram?
You don't profit from individual posts,
but those individual posts will boost your signal.
Yeah.
Some posts start profited Instagram.
You have to say,
add on.
It has to say sponsored post.
Right.
What?
Legally you're supposed to,
I'd probably say 90% of them aren't.
Right.
A lot of people don't write,
especially if it's like instant.